i've always wondered what are australian
conventions like
uh okay so i've only i mean there isn't
really a lot uh i've been to
i've been to two different ones uh there
is supernova which is more like a
comic-con yeah and then there is smash
which is the big anime con in sydney
right um the smash stand for anything
yeah the sydney mongrel anime show
good night yeah yeah so the first time i
went was in like
2013 14 something like that and there
was maybe like
3 thousand people four thousand people
it was a tiny convention um but the year
that i went uh before the pandemic where
i was a guest at there was like almost
like 30 40 000 people so it's like
clearly grown yeah massively um
in terms of but like i i i honestly
think like in terms of like the actual
like vibe of the con and stuff like that
i don't really see it as that much
different to like a us con or any other
like english speaking convention because
it's like everyone comes
yeah it's just yeah i mean not actual
cut switch yeah not actually we're not
actually so we're not throwing clothes
on well australian [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
i mean like even then though it's uh i
don't know
i i mean obviously i i felt a little
more at home because you know i was
talking to people with the same accent
yeah but um and you know because like
that was like my first con ever i was
like my home turf but um yeah in terms
of like a con experience i guess like
yeah i didn't really see it as that much
more different to like a standard like
american con i guess like the people i
feel just like weebs in general or like
anime fans in general like no matter
where you are kind of they kind of all
give off like the same vibe of like you
know a lot of them are just kind of like
chill and down to earth and just want to
like chat with you yeah i guess you know
because like in
australia like a lot like america where
is like you know a lot of stranger
friendliness is still pretty
prevalent right yeah so it's like you
know people didn't really have at least
not a lot of people didn't really have
problems you know coming up to me and
talking to me and stuff like that just
as like hey you know juggle some man you
know that kind of stuff like so
yeah i mean you i mean you guys will
definitely [ __ ] have a great time if
we ever end up going to smash right now
or an australian convention it's just
you know every now and then you will
meet those like very stereotypical loud
aussies who you know are just like
[ __ ] yeah you know like that's that
level right but that's good
that sounds that sounds like a laugh
yeah i feel though those kinds of people
you wouldn't really find it a lot of
like anime cons you'll see them at the
pub right but you know i very rarely
have i seen an anime fan dude it's my
convention do you love going to the pub
after that it's close
yeah like kirito
downing like a
you're like what's going on i don't
remember this part
it's like you know chicken like an
arsenal cosplay is like doing a shoei
you know yeah it's like that i like to
drink
i didn't unfortunately see that but we i
i wish i did do a lot of people get
drunk at aussie conventions because
that's a big thing about british
conventions way more than like so much
it is like it is like all they do it's
it's more than the actual convention
itself it's just people are just like oh
there's anime here cool let's get a
[ __ ] pint i mean
it's hard to say at least in sydney i
don't think it's would be as much as in
the uk just because like drinking or
eating out in sydney is really [ __ ]
expensive like you know like a pioneer
beer is like you know [ __ ] ten
dollars australian and like a lot of
like places in sydney right like in the
city um ten aussie dollars or yeah like
ten real dollars ten dollars ten dollars
a real currency ten dollars so you know
and i think to like a lot of kids who
come to these conventions you know like
ten dollars is a lot of money right like
that's cool that's ten dollars you could
spend on anime emoji at the corner yeah
of course um so i didn't see as many
drunk people as i thought there was
going to be but a lot of the parents
were getting drunk
you know they were like hey they've had
a hard day yeah like
drove like an hour to get into the city
and be like all right kids have fun at
your japanese convention
daddy and i are gonna go over to the pub
and get shit-faced while we wait for you
yeah so like i'm taking care of the kids
yeah like in between like signings and
stuff you know i'd take a step outside
and you know you look over at the like
the terrace of some of these like pubs
like on the water and you know there's
just a lot of parents clearly just like
waiting for their kids just being like
another people
yeah all right
can't blame them honestly i'd probably
do the same uh when i have kids you know
yeah like yeah because i i'm like an
only child so i never had this
experience but i remember like sydney
talking about it all the time where you
know
your parents would just take you to
events and then you would just give all
the responsibility to the older sibling
to take care of the [ __ ] take care of
the younger siblings and just like
here's a bunch of money [ __ ] off have
fun you know yeah i definitely have that
that's the [ __ ]
maybe i can't remember really maybe i
was a little [ __ ] so
i i think i've very rarely had
experiences like that because i think
like me and my sister didn't really like
share a lot of like the same like
interests when like when we were growing
up i feel like as adults now we're like
starting to like share more of like the
same likes on things but yeah i don't
really like remember going to like a lot
of events with my sister like we maybe
went to like a few concerts but did your
parents ever take you to an event that
you just didn't want to [ __ ] go to
but you had to go to because your
parents were going oh yeah matches
football matches my dad used to drag me
in football matches he's going to love
this bit now he's like i didn't drag you
he wanted to go no he would bribe me
with chocolate
he would he would be like i'll get i'll
buy you a like a galaxy bar
chocolate in the uk not like the small
bars yeah like the
this sized block one you know
we got some serious chocolate mileage
here he's like i'll buy it for you and
then i had to then this is the worst
part
my dad will laugh at this is that when i
was like eight
he would take me to like the pub before
yeah right right where where it was
literally like uh it's like a football
club right yeah yeah it's cheap it's
dirty it's absolutely rammed it stinks
it's like everyone is eating like pork
scratchings and downing like really
cheap pints right i actually remember
just sitting there just like not
understanding anything
although that they would just ask me
sometimes stuff about football and i'd
be like yeah
wayne rooney yeah
i never understood anything right and
one time i went to a match and everton
uh my my my dad's obsessed with like
everton family and stuff and i remember
they won because i was there and my dad
was like convinced that i was the good
luck charm yeah that's why we won so i
got dragged to more even though i told
them i hate it i do not want to go i i i
absolutely despise this because i would
just stand there it was cold and it was
so loud and i just wanted to play my
game boy yeah and i had to watch these
people kick and i was like why is it 90
minutes long
that's so long
so yeah to a child 90 minutes long
yeah and like i would always be like can
i get some like because i don't know why
i was a kid i just wanted to eat oh yeah
yeah i just wanted to eat and they would
sell those like stupidly long hot dogs
yeah at these football events yeah i
remember one time i i had one and uh my
dad let me like just hold on to like two
seconds and someone bumped into me and i
dropped it all right and then i just i
was just so mortified and i remember i
think that ruined football for me all
right no i'm done
i don't even need a whole 20 meals this
guy didn't even buy me a new one he like
knocked me over and i was like what the
[ __ ] yeah but i was like eight i didn't
articulate all i remember was i was just
really sad that i dropped this hot dog
right and you couldn't buy a new one
because it worked so my dad had just
given me like enough money to buy it and
it was like i couldn't you know i don't
know he'd like let me have it and i was
like oh my god no and then all the other
food was like oh it's really there's
like steak and kidney pies yeah from
like this thing called pucker pies in
the uk that's so bad they're really
really bad right but no i remember i
remember that like yeah i sort of liked
it but just remember being like totally
confused and not really understanding it
and i never really liked football yeah
my brothers did though they liked going
uh and my older brother liked it a lot
but i just never liked it and i felt
like i was a failure to my dad because
he was like i just want you to like
sports why can't you like sports why
can't you be a normal person and like
sports i'm like the only kid in the uk
that didn't like football i was like why
why
i remember like because my my parents
were like really into like looking at
property right
and for the longest time i was like oh
we're gonna are we gonna move house like
you know i would get excited i'm like no
it's like no we're just looking what and
i was like
we're literally window shopping houses
and they're like yeah and i was like two
or two like a ten-year-old i was like
what the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] is like the most privileged
non-privileged thing i've ever heard
well because it's like you know because
my dad is like you know heavily into
like stocks and like investing he's an
investment he's an investor i'm watching
i'm watching a home in the sun because
it's an investment yeah he was an
investor right and also like my parents
used to go a lot as well so that they
could get inspirations for like interior
design and stuff like that because you
know my dad loved doing like renovations
into the house and stuff so he would get
a lot of like good ideas from that right
it makes more sense um yeah but like you
know
to a 10 year old i don't know what the
[ __ ] like all that [ __ ] is right like
you would think if your parents came up
to you and said son we're gonna go check
out some houses today the first thing
you would think of as a ten-year-old is
yay we're moving right
and my sister who's like three years
younger than me was like we're moving
house that's so exciting yay so
naturally for the first couple of times
we'd go along with them right yeah until
we realize
we're not moving
we're just looking at them looking at
them